شكرا لعيال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
مازلنا في تغطيتنا متواصله لتداعيات كارثه
الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا ولا تزال
التاكيدات تتواصل من اكثر من جهه على
ضروره ايصال المساعدات الى سوريا واخرها
من البيت الابيض لكن سواء في سوريا او في
تركيا ينتظر اهالي من هم تحت الانقاض خبرا
عن ذويهم لكن الاخبار الجيده تراجعت الان
بشكل كبير للاسف لحسابي الاخبار السيئه
والامر طبيعي فنحن في اليوم الثامن من
الكارثه وفي ساعات قليله نتم اليوم الثامن
وندخل اليوم التاسع بعد كارثه الزلزال
[موسيقى]
الله
[تصفيق]
يا الله
[موسيقى]
من ركام الزلزال
انقاذ طفله من حضن اختها التي فارقت
الحياه
اخراج طفله من انقاض منزلها بعد 24 ساعه
من الزلزال
الله اكبر
رضيع ينجو من انهيار منزله
صبي يخرج حيا بعد ثلاثه ايام من الزلزال
انقاذ طفله ووالدها بعد 100 ساعه من
الزلزال
العثور على ناجيه قضت خمسه ايام تحت
الانقاض
انقاذ طفله بعد 150 ساعه من الزلزال
انا نازح وغير من دارس من اربع سنوات
فجاه اجا صار زلزال الساعه ثلاثه ثلاثه
ونصف اربعه بالضبط ما بعرف
نهدت البناي الجرح واحد من عندي من
الاولاد
الجرحى معبينا الشوارع الشهداء المشافعت
دمارك كتير بنايات لبينا نداء انه في مخيم
ايواء لانه اخواننا المضرين كثيرين وعم
نعمل بقدر الله عليه وسبحان الله انه الجو
برد مع كل هالبرد لبينا نداء واخواننا انا
نازح بحس بمعاد راح بيته ما ظل عنده ماوى
يعني لله الامر الحمد لله وين هلا عم نسمع
يعني نداء الصغار ان شاء الله وبتمنى من
كل واحد يعني قادر على العمل يعني يذهب
بشكل تطوعي
ويساعد اخواتنا
معنا من مدينه حارم في ادلب عاطف نعنوع
مدير فريق ملهم التطوعي اهلا بك مجددا في
هذه التغطيه استاذ عاطف بالامس وطيله هذه
التغطيه وانت تنقل لنا طبيعه الدعوات
الملحه والماسه بناء على حاجيات الناس هل
كان الوضع افضل اليوم هل سمعت هذه الدعوات
وماذا تتوقعون في الساعات والايام المقبله
مساء الخير الدعوات للناس متعاطفه مع
الشعب السوري للافراد
سمعت الحمد لله رب العالمين من خلال حمله
البث المباشر كتير ناس عم تتفاعل اشخاص
بدهم يعملوا اي شكل الشعب السوري بالنسبه
للمؤسسات والمنظمات ما زالت الاستجابه غير
مناسبه بحجم الكارثه غير مناسبه لاحد
القرنيسميها هي فعلا حادثه
القرن على مدار عشر سنوات كمان نحن نعرف
الشعب
اكثر مسوح في العالم يمكن العصر الحديث
وحده هاي البقعه الجغرافيه للاس الزلزال
فبالتالي المناطق اللي كان فيها 5000
خمسين الفلك ان تتخيل يعني حجم الكالسف
اليوم كان الوضع في شمال غرب سوريا مانو
احسن
دخول المساعدات من السعوديه ومن ومن قطر
في
لانه هاي المساعدات لا
تتناسب يمكن تدخل العدد من الشاحنات من
خلال معبر باب الهوى ما زال النظام عم
يتاجر بالقضيه من خلال معربه
بادخال المساعدات دائما الاعلام هو يعني
اللاعبين حكى بالاعلام او اللي احنا
شايفينه فعلا في تركيز على موضوع
المساعدات وانه لازم تكون هاي المساعدات
قيمه ذات قيمه حقيقيه مناسبه للواقع احنا
حاليا
عفوا باي معنى ذات قيمه ما المقصود بكلمه
ذات قيمه
انا ما فيني استقبل حاليا معدات للقص او
للبحث عن الانقاض ما فيني استقبل حاليا
وانا ما عندي ماوى
واضح بالصوت او او يمكن بالصوره نوضح
الهواء
درجه الحراره لاي شخص ممكن على جوجل
درجه مئويه الناس
بتصمم خيارات الخياطين
مراكز ايواء تناسب يعني المساعدات لا
تراعي اولوياتكم الان الحاجات الاساسيه
بشتغل عليه ان شاء الله
اما بالنسبه لنا نحن ما عندنا نحن بالشمال
السوري ما في ما في نشتريها كرمال نحط
الناس فيها الناس والطرقات الناس موجوده
عندهم ما في مكان يروحوا عليه فبالتالي
نحن حاليا بحاجه لمراكز ايواء الموجود
حاليا قديش بامن من حاجه الناس كخيام يعني
قديش النسبه اللي ما عندها خيام عمليا
في منطقه حارم حارم سلقين بعيد عنه شيء
عشره كيلو متر
وبعض المناطق الكفر تخاريم هاي المنطقه
صعبه الزلزال تمام اليوم بيجي لعندي احد
الاشخاص على هذا المكان انا فيه اللي
قدرنا ندبر بعد ثلاثه ايام 200 خيمه خياطه
يعني نحن عم نحكي كمنظمات السوري
بحس يامنوا عن طريق خياط
نحن عم نسعى لتامينهم من خلال ما
بعرفين سعره بالواقع فبالتالي هاي الخيم
حتكون مناسبه ما بعرف بس وصينا عليهم لانه
ما عندنا خيار تاني والله في في بالطرقات
الخياطين بغازي عنتاب عم يخيطوا برا المحل
هاي منطقه او دوله فيها مطارات عشرات
المطارات فيها معبر جوي مفتوح من قبل بعض
الدول الله يجزيه الخير
هو اصلا منكوب فبالتالي لما تدخل المساعده
فيها عشر الاف او مساعدات فيها 10,000 سنه
غذا يوزعون انا بس بدي انا موجود
انا ما بعرف
وين الناس الناس موجوده بالجوامع ناس
بعضهم اقربائه في احصائي في احصائيات
واضحه وصريحه بعد ما يتم التاسيس
مفهوم انا انا مدير الفريق
في 20 الف بدي اياك
والله العظيم
بسبب عدم التنسيق الكبيره بسبب طبعا هذا
الشيء طبيعي
حتى المؤسسات
المجتمع المدني او مؤسسات اداره المناطقم
ابدا لانه
غير قادرين على الاستجابه
ولكن على امل ان تصل هذه الدعوه ايضا
لتنظيم سلم الاولويات ومن ثم ايصال
المساعدات الاخرى اللازمه يعني واضح منسوب
الريح عندك مع البرد القارس الذي تعانون
منه مع شحا الامكانيات مناسف لذلك ولكن
نشكرك على وجودك معنا هذه الليله ايضا عطف
نعنوع مدير عاطف نعنوع مدير فريق ملهم
التطوعي من حارم في ادلب شكرا جزيلا
الى غازي عنتاب الان مع موفد العربيه الى
هناك عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن الكلمه
لك والمشهد من عندك ساعات قليله قبل يعني
دخولنا اليوم التاسع
نعم بالفعل طاهر قبل دخول اليوم التاسع
هنالك بعض المستجدات هنا في غازي عنتاب
وتحديدا في منطقه ابراهيم التي كانت
عمليات البحث عن الناجين فيها مستمره طوال
ثمانيه ايام الماضيه فرق الدوليه تم اعاده
توجيهها الى انطاكيا وايضا ربما كان هنالك
بعض الفرق التي غادرت المكان فعليا وبقيت
بعض الفرق التركيه المتبقيه نظرا لانه تم
تحديد فقط وجود اربعه
متوفين في تلك ذلك المكان تحديدا في
البراهيملي في غازي عنتاب فبالتالي انخفضت
بشكل كبير عمليات البحث عن نجيم في تلك
المواقع وتم توجيعه الى مواقع اخر وتبقت
فقط فرق فرق تركيا في تركيا في تلك
المنطقه وتوجيه الفرق الباقيه الى اماكن
اخرى اكثر حاجه تحدث عن انطاكيا التي بعد
التنسيق بين السلطات التركيه والفرق
اللغاتيه السعوديه تم توجيه الفريق
السعودي المكون من 100 فرد ومئه متخصص في
عمليات الانقاذ تم توجيههم الى انطاكيا او
بالفعل وذهبوا الى هناك اليوم
ليتمكنوا من العمل مع كافه الفرق على
البحث والاجلاء لعشرين او الفين منزل هدمت
في ذلك المكان بالاضافه الى تواد تواجد
عدد قليل جدا من فرق الانقاذ المتخصصه
اتحدث المصنفه حيث فرق الانقاذ في ذلك
المكان لا تتخطى ال 25 فريقا فبالتالي
الحاجه كبيره جدا وتم توجيه هذا الفريق
الى
انطاكيا الذي ذهب فعليا بالاضافه الى ذلك
لا تزال عمليات الانقاذ مستمره في منطقه
الاصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب وهي المنطقه
الاكثر تضررا هنا في غازي عنتاب عن البحث
عن ناجين في هذا اليوم الذي سيدخل يومه
التاسع بعد هذا الحدث الذي حصل الزلزال
الكبير الذي وقع في جنوب تركيا واثر حتى
وصل مدى الى شمال سوريا بالاضافه الى ذلك
تتفاقم ازمات مختلفه
للنازحين الذين لم يجدوا لهم ماوى خصوصا
بعد تهدم منازلهم او الاخرين الذين لم يكن
لديهم ماوى بعد ان اصبحت منازلهم غير امنه
هو هم منازلهم لم تنهار ولكنها غير امنه
للدخول فبالتالي توجهوا الى اما خرجوا
خارج غازي عنتاب او بقيوا في المدينه في
مختلف انحائها في الحدائق في الملاعب كره
القدم في الكنائس في المساجد في هذا
المحسن واذا كان بالامكان يعني تقنيا ان
نرى المشهد من خلفك اريد ان اسالك عن يعني
مقارنه
يمكن ان تجريها لنا بين ما تسمع عما حصل
في الشمال السوري من حال الناس وبين حالهم
في الجانب التركي الماساه ماساه على
الجميع ولكن بخصوص الامدادات والمساعدات
ربما اختلف الوضع قليلا كيف يمكن ان نقارن
نعم اضع لك الصوره من خلفيه حيث هذه
العائله التي لا تزال تمكث منذ وعددهم ما
يقارب اربعين شخص يمكثونه وهنا منذ وقوع
الزلزال وبخيمه بسيطه وبسيراتهم التي
ينامون بها
اما بالنسبه للوضع الوضع في بالمقارنه ما
بين تركيا وسوريا هنا الامدادات الاغاثيه
تصل بشكل متواصل وفي مطارات مختلفه نتحدث
عن مطار اضنه مطار غازي عنتاب وتصل مباشره
ويتم توزيعها وايضا يتم ايضا تقييم
الاوضاع بشكل عاجل كما حدث يوم الامس في
الطائره السعوديه التي وصلت محمله
باجهزه طبيه متقدمه بعد طلب السلطات
التركيه تم توفيرها من قبل
الجهات اللغاتيه السعوديه فبالتالي
العمليه مستمره في عمليه انقاذ ولكن
الحاجه كبيره جدا هنا في تركيا حيث ان
الكثير من الاشخاص لا زالوا في العراء
والبعض منهم لا ز متمسك بالعمل البسيط بان
يعود الى منزله فبعضهم مكث امام المنازل
البعض الاخر لازال في السيارات والبعض
الاخر قررها مغادره المدينه
بالمقارنه سوريه لا تزال الامدادات لم
تصلها بشكل كافي فقط سيارات قليله شاحنات
قليله جدا هي التي دخلت عكس تركيا التي
تتوفر لديها الامدادات ولكن الكارثه
والازمه اكبر بكثير مما وصل هنا في تركيا
بالرغم من
المساعدات الكبيره التي وصلت فرق الانقاذ
القادمه من مختلف دول العالم بالاضافه الى
المنظمات العموميه يعني منظر مش اصبح
معتاد في الشارع ان تشاهد سيارات
الشاحنات تحمل المساعدات وهي متوجهه الى
اماكن مختلفه بالاضافه الى ذلك حتى مع
وجود
هذه الخيم الايوائيه لا تزال المتطلبات
غير موجوده
طاهر
بهذه المخيمات تتحدث الان درجه الحراره
تحت الصفر
يعني الكثير لا يستطيع ان يمكث ويصمد امام
هذا الطقس البارد جدا
ويعني هذه الخيام لا تتوفر فيها وسائل
التدفئه سالتهم اليوم سالت احد السوريين
الذي يتواجد في خيمته في احد الحدائق كيف
تستطيعون الصمود امام هذا البرد القارس
قال لي بانهم يحاولون التدفئه باي طريقه
باشعال النيران للطبخ ولكنهم لا يطبخون
انما وضع المياه لمجرد وضعها والاحتماء
بالغاز وهذا ايضا موضوع خطير جدا لان
القيمه مغلقه وقد تسبب ايضا عمليات اختناق
اما اصابات او وفيات في الوضع في بالنسبه
لعمليات التدفئه لا تزال
والمدافع لا تزال غير متوفره دعني اختم
للاسف طاهر بخبر في ظل كومه الاخبار
السلبيه
والمحزنه يعني المليئه بالمئاسي خبر قبل
قليل من وزير الصحه التركي قال بان عدد
المواليد الذين ولدوا في مناطق الزلزال
خلال بعد الزلزال مباشره الى هذا اليوم
وصل الى
3700 مولود في المناطق التي وقع فيها
الزلزال وتضررت ربما هذا خبر يعني يرفع من
معنويات قليلا في ظل كومه هذه الاخبار
الماساويه ان ناتي بارقام مواليد وليس فقط
وفيات بعد هذا الزلزال شكرا على هذه
المعلومه عبد المحسن الحربي مفرد العربيه
الغازي عنتاب تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
اذا الخوذ البيضاء او الدفاع المدنيه
السوريه تتحدث عن ارتفاع ضحايا الزلزال في
شمال غرب سوريا الى
2274 قتيلا وما يزيد عن اثني عشر الف اثني
عشر الفئه مصاب اذا اخر احصائيات الدفاع
المدني السوري او الخوذ البيضاء عن حصيله
شمال غرب سوريا الجدار الحدودي بين تركيا
وسوريا لم يمنع سكان الاخيره من رؤيه
اختلاف التعامل مع الكارثه في البلدين ففي
جهتهم سوريون يشعرون بالخذلان هم منسيون
من الانقاذ والمساعدات العرش له
خذلان وتخلان وغضب مشاعر تختلط بالبرد
والفقد والدموع السوريون حملوا مجددا
اكياس الجثث التي اعتادوا حملها لسنوات
بعضهم حظي باقامه طقوس وداعا وان كانت
مختصره والبعض الاخر لا يزال بمرحله
انتظار خروجهم من تحت الانقاض
الحرقه لم تزل ببدايتها لكن الغضب عارم لم
يعتادوا البقاء في الصف الخلفي رغم اهمال
اوضاعهم لسنوات فصرخاتهم ليست لغطاء او
طعام رغم ضاله المساعدات التي وصلت الى
الشمال غرب سوريا وانعدامها ببعض المناطق
ما نريد اكل نريد ناكل التراب بس انحفظ
كرامتنا السوريون يصفونه بالتخلي
والنسيانه مع التماسهم لفروق كثيره في
التعامل المحلي والدولي مع جيرانهم
الاتراك شركائهم بالكارثه والدمار الكارثه
لم تقدر حدودا لكن الجدار بينهما حدد وحدد
خدمات كثيره من الانقاذ للاسعاف للماوى
فعلى الجهه الاخرى من الجدار الاف عمال
الانقاذ والالاف من المسعفين اضافه الى
معدات رفع ثقيله وجرافات وكلاب بوليسيه
تجب الشوارع صخب محركات تضغط عليه احيانا
صافره سيارات الاسعاف وزحام المساعدات لكن
في الجهه السوريه وقفت عمليات الانقاذ منذ
يومين صمت مستغرب تحتمه امكانات محدوده مع
تفوق الكارثه على قدرات الخوض البيضاء
نقاط التفتيش احبطت جهود الاغاثه الدوليه
والمساعده العاجله في الجزء الذي تسيطر
عليه الفصائل المدعومه من تركيا
والمساعدات المنتظره تعرقل دخولها لاكثر
من منطقه بسبب تقسيمات جغرافيه وانقسامات
سياسيه وولائيه
قال وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان انه من المهم جدا تامين وصول
المساعدات الى مستحقها في مناطق تركيا
وسوريا كافه
الكارثه التي حلت بكل من تركيا وسوريا
كبيره جدا وتقتضي توفير المساعدات
المناسبه المملكه ردت على الكارثه من خلال
ارسال المساعدات وفرق الاغاثه الى كلا
البلدين ونشجع الجميع على تقديم المساعدات
وفق ما تم بحثه في الاجتماع الثنائي مع
المندوب السامي السيد مرعب ومن المهم جدا
تامين وصول المساعدات الى مستحقيها في
تركيا وسوريا كافه يجب العمل على تخفيف
معاناه الشعب السوري ونبذر ما بوسعنا من
اجل وصول المساعدات الى المناطق كافه في
الداخل السوري
قال منسق لاستجابه الطارئه بالجمعيه
الدوليه لرعايه الكوارث والذي يعمل في
مخيم الاغاثه السعودي في جنديرس في شمال
غرب سوريا قال ان عمليه توزيع المساعدات
السعوديه التي وصلت من مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه في جنديرس بدات
الطائره دخلت من خلال معبر جوي اغاثه بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وبين تركيا طبعا
هاي الطائرات دخل منها الى سوريا قافيه
واحده اللي هي عباره عن 11 شحنه بقيه
الحمولات حيث يتم توزيعها بين سوريا
وبتركيا بالنسبه للجانب السوري فاللي دخل
هو عباره عن 11 شاحنه من خلال معبر الحمام
الحروري مع تركيا هاي الشواحين تتضمن عده
مواد اللي هي مواد غذائيه خلال غذائيه
ومواد غير غذائيه اللي هي طبعا كانت عباره
عن خيم وسلال ايواء واغطيه
للناس اللي ضررت يؤثر الزلزال اللي صار
جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا طبعا هاي المواد
توزيعها بمناطق ادلب ومناطق عفرين نحن
حاليا متواجدين بوسط من ناحيه جنديرس عم
نقوم ببناء واحد المخيمات طبعا هذا المخيم
رقم ثلاثه اللي احنا عم نباشر فيه ان شاء
الله وغدا الفرق راح تكون متواجده بمناطق
ادلب لا ان شاء الله رب العالمين حنحاول
نوصل لاكبر عدد ممكن من خلال الفتره
القادمه
ان يعني ان يدخل قليلا الى الى
الخيام ولكن التجهيزات هنا تخوننا دائما
التجهيزات الانترنت صعوبه التواصل تخوننا
دائما في الدخول بين الاهالي ولكن في
النشرات القادمه سندخل بين الاهالي
سنستضيفهم طبعا كما تلاحظون على شاشه
الكاميرا هناك العديد من العوائل التي اتت
الى هنا تنتظر الانتهاء من بناء هذه
الخيام لكي يستلموها لكي يؤمنوا انفسهم
بعد ايام عصيبه مرت عليهم في ظل موجات
البرد الشديده التي تضرب المنطقه ليل
الامس يعني صراحه كانت درجه الحراره هنا
ناقص درجتان اغلب هؤلاء الاهالي كانوا
يبيتون في مراكز الايواء المؤقته منهم من
كان يبيت امام منزله المدمر بشكل جزئي
يخاف دخوله نتيجه يعني وجود هزات ارتداديه
تحدث
الحين والاخر
من غازي عنتاب احمد رحمه من منظمه اطباء
بلا حدود اهلا بك كيف هو الواقع الطبي
والاستشفائي والدواء في اليوم الثامن قبل
قبيل انتهائه
اهلا بكم وبستاد المشاهدين في قناه
العربيه اخي الكريم للاسف يعاني قطاع
الصحي في شمال غير سوريا من من كارثه
انسانيه
[موسيقى]
القطاع الصحي تعرض لتدميه ممنهج خلال 12
سنه الماضيه
دمرت معظم المنشات الصحيه
بالوضع الصحي كارثي الامدادات الصحيه في
وضع صعب جدا معظم المنشات الصحيه تعاني من
نقص شديد في التمويل وفي الامدادات الطبيه
منذ اليوم الاول كان هناك حاجه شديده
لامداد معظم المنشات الصحيه بالعديد من
المواد منذ اليوم الاول عدد كبير من
المنشات الصحيه لم تكفيها
المستودعات الموجوده لديها لتغطيه المرضى
في اليوم الاول اليوم نحن في اليوم الثامن
ولا زالت امتدادات الصحيه من مواد اوليه
ومستهلكات طبيه وادويه ومعدات طبيه قليله
الوصول الى الداخل في شمال غرب سوريا ما
زلنا نتحدث في منظمه اطباء بلا حدود معلش
نركز اكثر على ما الذي استطعتم ان تقدموه
حتى الان في مختلف المناطق المتضرره
حقيقه نحن منذ اليوم الاول
فتحنا معظم جميع مستودعاتنا والموجود من
المستودعاتنا كافه المنشات الطبيه العامله
في جمال غرب سوريا
المواد الطبيه المتوفره لدينا من مستهلكات
طبيه وادويه لانقاذ الجرحى ومعالجه
المصابين ولكن يعني علينا ان نشير انها لا
تكفي قد تكون نقطه في بحر من الاحتياجات
الضخمه التي يحتاجها المنشات الصحيه في
شمال سوريا
الان ما دعوتكم ولمن
للاسف كل شيء يحتاج الناس للناس فقدوا
بيوتهم فقدوا منازلهم فقدوا ارزاقهم فقدوا
احبائهم فقدوا كل شيء كل ما يقدم هو هو
يعني يعتبر احتياجات اساسيه الناس في
العراء للاسف اخي الناس فقدت بيوتها فقد
احبابها
في هذا يعني تسلسل الكوارث على الشعب
السوري خلال الفتره الاخيره خلينا نقول
يعني من شتاء قارص من موجه ثلوج من اصابات
من اغلاق المعابر من الان كارثه الزلزال
التي قد تكون كارثه القرن حقيقه كلها
كوارث تاتي على راس الشعب السوري
الاحتياجات طبيه شديده جدا كبيره جدا حتى
اليوم نحن نتحدث عن اليوم اقتراب يوم
التاسع من الكارثه وما زالت المنشات
الصحيه تعاني من نقص شديد في الاحتياجات
وادخالات المواد عبر الحدود لا تزال في
كميات ضئيله جدا نتحدث عن بضع شاحنات من
التي دخلت عبر الحدود وهذا رقم جدا ضئيل
من هنا من هذا المنبر علينا ان نشير
للضروره فتح المعابر لضروره ان لا يكون
الامر مقتصر على معبر واحد الادخالات انه
قد تكون قليله جدا
معلش نركز معك اكثر لو تكرمت على الطبيعه
الادويه التي تحتاجونها
والاطباء الذين تحتاجون تحتاجونهم وطبيعه
الاصابات التي نتجت الخوذ البيضاء تتحدث
الان عن اكثر من اثني عشر الف مصاب فقط في
الشمال الغربي لسوريا حيث المناطق
المتضرره
نعم اخي الاحتياجات يعني اليوم نتحدث
بدايه كنا نتحدث عن احتياجات في
الاصابات
الناتجه عن ردود ناتجه عن سقوط المنازل
والمباني
المواد التجهيزات
المتعلقه بالجراحه العظميه والجراحه
العامه والمشافي
ولكن بعد تجاوز هذه المرحله نحن نحتاج
لاعاده بناء الصحه الاوليه الصحه النفسيه
الصحه النفسيه الوضع كارثه في سوريا الان
طبعا سنه من الحرب الوضع كارثي للاسف
والصحه الاوليه كذلك بالاضافه الى ان
الناس
كبير في الاطباء نفسيين بدون شك
بدون شكوى كح كبير في الكوادر الطبيه
تتحدث للاسف عن عن اكثر من قرابه المئه
الدوله اعلنت استجابتها للكارثه الطرف من
الحدود ولكن من الطرف الاخر من الحدود لا
يوجد احد للاسف يعني قد لا يتجاوز الاصابع
اليد الواحده الدول التي استجابت في شمال
غرب سوريا يعني هناك لجوء لطرق البدائيه
في في التطبيب وفي العلاج الان
تماما يعني الامر ينعكس من الدفاع المدني
عمليات الانقاذ تبدا عمليات انقاذ من خلال
الادوات اليدويه البسيطه لانقاذ وكذلك
الامر يعني ينسحب على المجال الطبي للاسف
في بعض المشافي وبعض المنشات الطبيه يكاد
الكوادر تعمل بالحدود الدنيا للمعايير
الطبيه والسبب ليس ليس سوء من من الكوادر
الطبيه ولكن لا يوجد لديها ايه امكانيات
لاكمال لاكمال العمل بشكل افضل يعني من
هذا ندعو الى فتح الطعام الى ايصال
يكفيه الشعب السوري ما عانى خلال 12 سنه
واعتقد انه الان الوقت المناسب اليوم
كارثه على على في منطقه جغرافيه واحده
نرجو ليكفي خزلان للشعب الكوري في هذه
الامر شكرا جزيلا لك احمد رحمه من منظمه
اطباء بلا حدود من غازي عنتاب تحياتي اليك
في روايه مؤلمه لاحد الشبان السوريين
المتطوعين لانقاذ الاشخاص العالقين تحت
الانقاض يروي المتطوع لمراسلنا ان احد
العالقين طلب منه قطع رجله لانقاذه لانه
لم يعد يحتمل البقاء تحت الركام قبل ان
يتمكن المتطوع اخيرا من انقاذه سبحان الله
العائله تركيا اخرجناهم بعون الله تمينا
شي ثلاث ساعات حتى نقدر نوصل لعندهم بعد
ما وصلنا الاخت طلعت سليم ما فيها شيء
والرجل على اجره تحت الاركان بين الباطون
تمينا اربع او ثلاث ساعات كمان بس التحرير
رجله سبحان الله اخر شيء فقد الامل وقال
اقطع اجري يا الله اي والله قال اقطع اجري
واخرجني قلت له لا يا اخي ان شاء الله انا
بدي احاول لحتى احرر سبحان الله الحمد لله
الله عز وجل
وتخلى عن رجله حتى بلحظه اي والله عن رجله
حتى يخرج بدنه الحمد لله الله وحررنا
الموقف الاخر لانه ما عندناش وقت كثير اسف
بس يعني موقف الاخر سبحان الله اخرجنا طفل
في عمر 11 سنه
قبل ما نوصل لعندو سالناه مين معك قال
خالتي وابن خالتي قلنا له مين متوفي قال
بس لاخرج ان شاء الله انا استغربت من ذكاء
الطفل قال بس ان شاء الله اخرج نتكلم بعد
ما خرج قال خالتي عايشه وابنها متوفي
سبحان الله جوا ما قال هذا الحكي مشان ما
يسمع خالتو خالتو ما بتعرف انه ابنه متوفي
عشان ما يجرحها يعني عشان عشان ما يجرحها
تحت الركام
بخوف وحذر تهافه الرجال الانقاذ لانتشاله
ليستقبلهم هو بضحكاته البريئه انه رضيع
الانقاض الضاحك ابن الستين يوما صمد امام
الزلزال المدمر وبقي تحت الركام لخمسه
ايام في انطاكيا التركيه وحين خرج للنور
تغلبت براءته على معاناته وضحك الرضيع
الضاحك شغل الجميع منذ لحظه نقله الى
المستشفى في مدينه اضنه التركيه بقي
الصغير تحت الانقاض لمده خمسه ايام ثم نقل
الى المستشفى بواسطه الاسعاف الجويه لكن
حالته العامه جيده فهو بخير الطفل الضاحك
مجهول الهويه لا يعرف اسمه ولم يتم التوصل
الى والديه حتى الان لكن الطاقم المستشفى
الذين يعملون جاهدين لرعايته اكدوا انه
سيبقى معهم بعد ان اسر قلوبهم بضحكاته
البريئه
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
محمود شكر موفد العربيه اهلا بك محمود كيف
يبدو الوضع عندك والصوره من خلفك لو سمحت
نعم طهر في اليوم الثامن وبعد قليل في
اليوم التاسع اختلفت الصوره والمشهديه
وايضا التقديمات الاساسيه والمساعدات في
هذه المدينه ويبدو الى ان هنالك دفع من
قبل الشركات الخاصه بالحكومه التركيه
والجامعات والمنظمات الاهليه الى مزيد من
كل التقنيات الحديثه لعمليه تقديم الاغاثه
هنا في هذه الشركه التي هي مطعم في الاساس
في اسطنبوله في انقره وعندها عده من
المطاعم قامت اليوم بنصب هذه الخيمه والان
هؤلاء مجموعه من المتطوعين يقومون بطهي
الطعام الذي يوزع مجانا على كل من هو قائم
في هذا المخيم بالاضافه ايضا كما نشاهد
هذا الجزء الثاني من ياتي الى هنا وهذا
المركز يضم ما يقارب ثلاثه الى اربعه الاف
من النازحين في الداخل التركي بالاضافه
الى هنا السوريين اذا ذهبنا الى هذه
السيارات
طاهر هذه ما هي هي سيارات البث
للتليفونات الذي لا يملك لا يملك هاتفا
خلويا يمكن له ان ياتي الى هناك ثم بعد
ذلك يجري الاتصالات ما يسمى بالخط الارضي
كل ما هو تقني وحديث ومتطور قام المنظومه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه في
تركيا بجزه ودفعه الى الاماكن التي حصل
فيها هنا ايضا يقدمون الشيء الساخن ايضا
ايضا في هذه الخيمه التي سترى فيها يعني
ترى فيها الغرابه او ايضا العجابه من
الامر كيف وصلت الامور في اداره عمليه
المساعدات والتقنيات سنذهب الى هذه الخيمه
وايضا سنرى الان ماذا يجري
نرى
مواطنه تركيه تحمل مجموعه من الخبز هو
الان الساخن سندخل الى الداخل ايضا
ونشاهد ماذا الذي يجري نشاهد الخبز الساخن
كيف يجري ويتم توزيعه مباشره على كل من هو
موجود في المدينه هنا ايضا هذا الطحين هذه
الالات هذه مجموعه من المتطوعين وايضا علم
هذا الفرن ركب على عجل على عجاله او على
عشره من امره كما نشاهد الان الخبز في
الفرن ايضا يخبز ثم بعد ذلك يؤتى الى هنا
كما نشاهد العمال
هنا في هذا الجزء الخبز الذي ايضا يعمل
مباشره هو على مدار ال 24 ساعه لربما يقدر
يقدم العشرات من الاطنان الجاهزه في هذا
المخيم كما تشاهد الان هذه العمليه
بالاضافه ايضا نتحدث عن ثلاثه عناوين
اساسيه الخبز الطعام
مشرب الشراب الساخن ايضا الى الخيم الطبيه
التي وصل عدد كبير من الاطباء الممرضين
الممرضات هي دوره اقتصاديه اجتماعيه
معيشيه قائمه بحد ذاتها في كل المخيمات
التي اقيمت على الاراضي التركيه بالاضافه
ايضا الى ان هذا المركز هو مركز توزيع الى
المناطق الاخرى نعم
بالشاورما التي هي كانت موضوعه في اماكن
متعدده ومن اراد ان ياكل عليه فقط ان
ينتظر لنصف ساعه وياخذ يحتاج كل
الحاجات الاساسيه التي يتطلبها
الانسان في معيشته هم لربما حصلوا عليه
لربما الصوره الان يعني ساذهب الى الخارج
حتى نكون من قضيه درجه الحراره هؤلاء
مجموعه من الناس ينتظرون الان لاخذ ما
يريدونه بالاضافه ايضا الى هذه المجموعه
من الطحين المقدس وهذا يعمل به على مدار
ال 24 ساعه كما اشرت معك يظهر يظهر الى ان
هنالك دفع جديد بكل ما يحتاجونه من من
طعام المواد من شراب من تقديمات على عكس
كنت قد استمعت معك الى السؤال للزميل عن
الواقع السوري والواقع التركي بالاضافه
ايضا كما نشاهد الان الشاي الذي يقدم وهذه
منصات او هذه مواقع هي موجوده ليست هنا
بالعشرات بل هي بالمئات وهي موزعه نحن كنا
نقوم بجولات متعدده على طول على طول هذه
المدينه ووجدنا هذا هذا الشيء وايضا هذه
التقديمات المترابطه مع بعضها البعض والتي
تدار من غرفه عمليات مركزيه
موحده هذه غرفه العمليات عندها القدره
لتعرف من هو الان من الفرق الذي يعمل في
الانقاذ على طول الاراضي التركيه من هي
الفرق التي وصلت من الشاحنات والمواد
الغذائيه الى الاراضي التركيه
حتى انه الخشب اذا تحدثنا عن الخشب بالامس
واليوم وصلت كما ترى درجه الحراره تقراي
تقريبا تحت الصفر وصل العشرات من الشاحنات
التي تنقل الحطب وقامت بتوزيعه بكل
الشوارع من يريد الخيام متوفره مواد
التدفئه متوفره
الاغذيه متوفره الادويه متوفره لكل من
يحتاجها في هذه الخيم وهذا جيد جدا
بالنسبه الى الاتراك وكل من كان مقيما
واستفاد من ذلك هناك ولكن للاسف لا يبدو
هذا على المقلب الاخر في الجانب السوري
كما قلنا على الاطلاق انما الحاجيات كبيره
جدا وهي حاجات ماسه بالنسبه الى المتضررين
يعني ولكن بدون شك الكل يريد ايواء دائما
وعوده الى البيوت بعد ترميمها او الى بيوت
جديده بدون شك محمود هذا امل الناس هناك
الان
طاهر معك تفضل
انظر الى هذه الحافلات الان التي تنقل
ايضا
المتطوعين الذين ياتون من المناطق
ويوزعونهم على مناطق العمل كيف نشاهد او
لا مجموعه من المتطوعين ايضا مجموعه من
العمال هذا في
الباص الاول نرى هنا الباص الثاني نرى
ايضا الباص الثالث كل الامور هنا منظمه
حتى انها منظمه بالملبس يعني كل فريق ننظر
هنا كل فريق له لباس خاص به كل مجموعه لها
لباس خاص بها وكل مجموعه لها لها مهمه
معينه غيرها كنت اسالك عن الوعود التي
قدمت الى الناس ما الذي يقولونه الناس ما
الذي يقولونه لك بخصوص الوعود التي قدمت
لهم للمده التي يمكن ان يقضوها في اماكن
الايواء المؤقته وما البدائل
طاير من الصعوبه بما كان الحد من الصعوبه
بمحل ماء الحديث عن هذه المساله لان نحن
في المدينه التي نحن بها هي مدينه زلزلت
من اصلها الى فصلها الى فروعها والحل
الاساسي بها ان تقوم الحكومه بانزالها على
الارض كل الاحياء ثم بعد ذلك يبنى على
الشيء مقتضاه بعمليه البناء ولكن ايضا اذا
وفقنا في اليومين المقبلين سنذهب الى
مخيمات بدا العمل فيها ما يسمى بالكونتينر
مدينه باكملها
موزعه هم بداوا اليوم بوضعها غدا علمت الى
انهم سيقومون بتوزيعها بوصل الكهرباء ثم
بعد ذلك المفارقه او المشاهدات الحيه هو
انه عندما زرنا هذا المكان انظر هنا فقط
كذلك طاهر العمليات ايضا وغرف المستشفيات
المستشفيات الثابته والمستشفيات
متحركه وايضا بالقرب من هذه بالقرب من هذا
المخيم توجد ايضا مستودعات مليئه مليئه
بالادويه يعني الادويه المخزنه الادويه
المنظمه هي هنا بهذا الطريق يعني كان
بالامس حاولنا الدخول الى هذا الى هذا الى
هذا المخيم فطلبوا منا انه عدم الدخول
اليه حرصا على على المرضى او حرصا منهم في
بالقرب منه كما نشاهد هذا المخزن المليء
من الادويه بالاضافه ايضا الى هنا الخيام
المتوزعه والمتنوعه والتي يوجد فيها اما
الجماعه من المتطوعين واما ايضا من
الاتراك واما ايضا من السوريين وكما نشاهد
ايضا الحطف في الارض هو وصل الى هذه
المدينه اقله بمجم
ليس بمئات الاطنان لربما بالاف لانه على
الطريق كنا نشاهد هذا الحطب المقسم
والمجزا والمقطع والمجهز ايضا
للنار حتى انه ترى العجابه الى انهم في
هذه الايام صنعوا مدافئ من حديد جاهزه
ومركبه للطرقات يعني لربما انت تضع هذه
المدفاه بقربك مباشره ثم بعد ذلك تقوم
بوضع الخشب بها ثم بعد ذلك بالتدفئه
بالتالي نتوقع ان يكون حال الناس بان
الحكومه استطاعت ان تمتص الصدمه ونقمه
الناس وان تحتوي الموقف ولو لم يكن ذلك في
اليومين او الايام الثلاثه الاولى هذا حصل
يعني على الاقل في المركز حيث انت ووفق
مشاهداتك ووفق ما تسمع من الناس
نعم صحيح الكلام الان الى ان الامور بدات
تاخذ مجراها الطبيعي على مستوى عوده دوره
الحياه الى طبيعتها بمعنى اننا جئنا الى
هنا في اليوم الاول زرنا كان هذا المكان
يوجد فيه اقله اقله عشره الاف مواطن تركي
الان يوجد فيها مجموعات مجموعات متخصصه مع
بعضها تقدم المعونه من بقي دخل الى الخيام
من لم يبقى ذهب
به او اخذ الى محافظات اخرى او الى مدن
اخرى من تبقى ايضا سيذهب الى الكونتنيرات
في المدينه الطعام
يقدم هنالك مطابخ سندخل في الساعات
القادمه الى كيف تطبخ الطعام وايضا ايضا
بالليل امس مع ساعات الفجر نزلت البلديه
لكنس الشوارع كان لافتا الى ان مدينه
باكملها على الارض
عشرات من العمال البلديه وهم يكنسون
الشوارع مفارقه بدون كذلك حديث
اكتفي معك بهذا القدر مفرد العربيه الى
اليمن اعذرني على المقاطعه شكرا جزيلا
محمود على هذه الرساله الوافيه تحياتي
اليك ولنعود اليك في سياق هذه التغطيات
المستمره ان شاء الله
حنان ناجي سوريا بقيت تحت الانقاض فيها
طاي لايام تروي للعربيه قصه نجاتها وتقول
ان شعور الخوف لم يفارقها حتى بعد خروجها
من تحت الانقاض وهي تشعر الى الان باهتزاز
الارض التي لم يتوقف ما في اتصالات هنا
فكروني طلعت انا وانه بعدوا يعني موقف
كتير صعب يعني لهلا ببرك بقعد بصرخ بقلم
الارض عم بتهز الارض عم بتهز اي لهلا
ولهلق اذا هلق بركي والله وحاسه انه الارض
وانت تصرخي وما حد يسمعك
من كثر ما انا بدي اسمع انا بدي اسمع هذه
التجربه ولو انها يعني دموعك والله يعني
بمجرد بس ما بتخيل الموقف يعني هم بيقولوا
لي حرام بتموتي قلت لهم اللي شفتهم
قدامي عم بشوفهم المطر عم تنزل علينا
بس انا صاحي بعد هالنهار ما بعرف شو صار
مطر تحت المطر والبرد وصدر فيها وصيح راح
صوتك مثل ما بصيح ما في اصابات الحمد لله
لا
طيب ثلاث ايام اللي عشتيها تحت الانقاض
انت لديك تجربه مرعبه يعني انا اعرف
واعتذر
ايش اللي شعرتي فيه البرد
صعب
بعد ما طبت وانا فكرته انه هن راحت طبت
عليهم
من انقذك كيف صارت عمليه الانقاذ
راح صوتك
معنا من الحدود السوريه التركيه الصحفي
خالد ابو المجد اهلا بك مجددا خالد في هذه
التغطيه كيف اختلف اليوم الثامن
نعم طاهر اليوم يخيم الحزن بشكل كبير على
عدد كبير من المدنيين والسبب في ذلك بان
في الايام السابقه كان الجميع ينشر على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي او حتى في محيطه
عن اشخاص فقدهم وربما يكون ناجين اما
الدعوات ليوم النشر اليوم يتم على نعوه
عدد كبير من الاشخاص وهم فقدوا تحت
الانقاذ او تم انتشالهم كجثث طبعا ان عواد
سابقا كانت السوريون على مدار السنوات
الطويله كانوا من هنا ابنائهم واولادهم
فرادى لكن يوم النعوات تبدو جماعيه
وعائليه بشكل كبير اما على الصعيد المدني
طبعا الجميع يعلم بان ما شاهدناه في سوريا
ماساه بكل معنى الكلمه عشره الاف العائلات
هجرت من منازلها التي دمرت بشكل كامل
والان هذه العائلات تسكن الطرقات والمساجد
وكذلك حدائق العامه
والمساعدات الامميه التي وصلت ربما هي
ليست على قدر مسؤوليه لكن تفي بالغرض بشكل
قليل وطبعا هذه المساعدات يتم بناء من
خلالها الجدير بالذكر بان قافيه سعوديه
كبيره كانت تضم عدد من الخيام وكذلك قافله
من الامم المتحده وكذلك قافله قطريه هناك
بناء لبعض المخيمات لكن هذه المخيمات لم
تكفي كل الذين هجروا من تحت الانقاذ
الجدير بالذكر هو خبر ربما هو بصيص من
الامل وسط كل هذا الظلام معلومات قمت
بتسجيلها حتى يعني اسمعها اياكم قبل بعد
اكثر من 180 ساعه تم انقاذ رجل من انطاكيا
وكذلك من اديه من بعد اكثر من 175 ساعه
وكذلك طفله سوريه منقاذها من منطقه
اسكندرون هذا الكلام ماذا يعني يعني بانه
رغم طول الايام ودخلنا في اليوم الثامن
لكن هناك
بعض الاشخاص يقاومون تحت الانقاذ وهناك
عائلات ما تزال عائشه على الامل وتطالب
فرق الانقاذ سواء كانت في سوريا او بتركيا
بان لا يقطعوا لهم الامل ولا يتوقفوا عن
عمليات اجلاء الاشخاص من تحت الانقاذ وان
لا يعتمدوا الجميع هنا لم يسمع صوت فانهم
موتى هناك امال كبيره يعيشها المدنيون كما
ذكرت هذه الاشخاص او هذه الحالات التي
ذكرتها اليوم والبارحه تم انقاذهم هذا
الشيء يبعث الامل في نفوس عشره الاف
الاشخاص الذين ينتظرون عوائلهم ربما
يكونوا على قيد الحياه ما المطلوب في
الايام المقبله خالد
هل تقصد انسانيا طبعا على كل الاصعده
المجال مفتوح لكم يعني تعبر عن اهم
الحاجات الاساسيه
لكي يعني تطلب المساعدات اللازمه من
الجهات المتخصصه اقليميا ودوليا لكي
ترسلها
السوريين كبيره المطلوب في الوقت الاني او
المطالب الحاليه هي انقاذ الاشخاص الذين
هجروا وتامين اماكن عيش مؤقته تحميهم من
برد الشتاء القارص حاله البرد الان ربما
بالصفر او ما دون الصفر هناك بعض العائلات
تفترش الاراضي الزراعيه وتفترش كذلك
الحدائق المطلوب الاني هو انتشال هؤلاء
العائلات من تحت
برد الشتاء القارس
ومحاوله لملم الجراحهم وكذلك وضعهم على
اقل تقدير في قيام او في اماكن تاويهم ولو
كان مؤقتا اما او اما على الصعيد البعيد
ما هو مطلوب المطلوب بان تلتفت الامم
المتحده ان تعي ذلك بان هناك في الشمال
السوري شعب دمر وقتي على مدى عشر اعوام
يجب الجميع ان يلتفت لهذا الشعب الخذلان
هو ليس يعني ان لا نتكلم بعاطف يعني احول
موضوع العاطفي لكن حقيقه يجب على المجتمع
الدولي ان يتذكر بان في هذه البقعه
الجغرافيه يوجد اشخاص يموتون ما يفرق
السوري عن الكويتي عن العراقي ان عن
الاوروبي كلنا بشر ولكن في هذه البقعه
تعتقد بان هناك اناس منسيون هل هم في هذه
البقعه الجغرافيه المطلوب على المدى
البعيد ان يتذكر الجميع بان في هذه البقعه
الجغرافيه لهم اخوه ولهم اهل ولهم اناس من
لحم ودم اهتمام بهم من الضروري جدا حتى
تنتهي ماساه السوريين شكرا جزيلا لك خالد
ابو المجد الصحفي من الحدود التركيه
السوريه تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]